مشاهدينا من القاهره استاذ امراض القلب
وعميد معهد القلب السابق الدكتور جمال
شعبان اهلا بك دكتور معنا في صباح العربيه
اهلا بحضرتك وصباح جميل سعيد من القاهره
لاهل العربيه ولكل قلوب العرب وتمنياتي
لكل قلوب العرب ان تكون بصحه وسلام وخير
وعافيه ان شاء الله طيب الدكتور خلينا
نبدا لو حبذا لو تضعنا في صوره تفاصيل
الاحداث اللي جرت والحديث اللي جرى بينك
وما بين الفنان محمد رمضان
يعني هو قبل الحديث انا كنت دايما برضو
بنتقد هذا الاسلوب بتاعه بس اسلوبي يعني
ما كانش يعني بيتخطى حدود اللياقه يعني
انا اهتم جدا ان انت لما تواجه نقد
الانسان
تواجهه باسلوب جميل غير الاسلوب الحادي
اللي بيظهر احيانا على السوشيال ميديا
والاستقطاب الحادي اللي بيظهر في السوشيال
ميديا المره دي انا قلت طيب احاول ادي له
بقى حل فقولت له انا شايف ان انت وانت
متصور مع الدولارات يعني مش باصص لها يعني
شكلك كده مش محتاج لها فانا عندي حالات
بتعاني من اختلال كهربائي القلب حالات
خطيره
وكانوا منزلين على صفحتي من يومين شاب
عنده 18 سنه عنده خطر التوقف القلب
المفاجئ ومحتاج جهاز صدمات كهربيه تمنه
بيتجاوز 200 الف واحيانا بيصل ال 300,000
جنيه مصري
فقال لي طيب حاول تقول لي اسماء ومستشفيات
محتاجه وبعت لي رقمك على الخاص بعثت له
الرقم فاتصل بيا تاني يوم الصبح وبعد كده
اتفقنا واتقابلنا بالليل وازهر استعداده
للمشاركه في علاج الحالات وطلبنا اول حاله
مصريه بسيطه من الصعيد ما كانتش مصدقه ان
هو بيكلمها وانا كنت معاه
وان شاء الله يتم تركيب هذا الجهاز هيتكفل
هو بكل النفقات بتاعته ناس كتير يقول لك
ده مال من حرامي ازاي ما اعرفش
يا حبايبي دكتور استعداد اروح لاي انسان
في اي حته هل ستكون مساعده الفنان محمد
رمضان هي مساعده واحده ام عمليه مستمره
وبالتالي هو يعني من كان يشاهد يقول والله
لديه اموال وبالدولارات اذا هي تعطيك مبلغ
كبير في اذا حولتها الى الجنيه المصري هل
سيكون هذا عمليه مستمره ولا هي مره واحده
وخلاص شو اعلامي كما يقال لا
ايه الوعد اللي خان شو اعلامي خالص هو على
فكره ما هو اخدته ان هو هيقف في كل في كل
هذه الحالات الوعد قال ان في كل هذه
الحالات بل هو بيفكر وانا اقترحت عليه
يعمل مؤسسه يعني تبقى مشهره لدعم هذه
الحالات بحيث يبقى بطريقه مؤسسيه بدل ما
تبقى حلاته كده عابره يبقى في نشاط مؤسسي
جمعيه خيريه تتبنى هذه الحالات الخطيره
اللي مش قادره وهو قال لي ان امه هي اللي
بتوجهه في القصه دي ان هو بيودي للقصر
العيني ويودي لابو الريش وبيشتري حضانات
وحاجات ما بيحبش يعلن يعني الدكتور جمال
ما تكلمت معاه انه ليه بيعمل هذه الحركه
ليه بيحط الفلوس جنبه على الطياره اكيد
هذا سؤال بديهي اتكلمت معاه
اتكلمت معاه اتكلمت معاه وقال لي والله
العظيم انا لا اقصد استفزاز الناس لاننا
رجل من البسطاء وطلعت من البسطاء
فيها ناس كثير من البسطاء دي رسائل بيقول
دي رسائل بواجهها لناس معينين
يعني انا لما كتبت هذا المنشور ونشرته كان
عندي احساس داخلي كده ان هو يرد ما اعرفش
ليه بس جالي هذا الاحساس فهو رد بالليل
وقعدوا يبعتوا لي رسايل رد عليه بقى هو
عايز يتواصل معك جمهور كتير يعني تاني يوم
لما تواصلت معه لما قابلته هو انسان ذكي
مجتهد بيشتغل بطريقه منهجيه واخد الفن
يعني عمل احترافي مكتب وشغل بيقول لي
بذاكر وبدرس وعندي فريق عمل وبيخطط لكل
حاجه واعتقد هذه الرسائل هو بس الوحيد
اللي يعرف مين لكن هي حاجات مش انا مع
حضرتك هي مش حاجات عشوائيه ولا هبه هازرد
ولا بيعملها لا هو قاصد يوجه رسائل معينه
لكن حسب كلامه ان دي مش مقصود بيها
استفزاز الشارع
لا يكون راضي كل هذا الرضا عنها على كل
حال شكرا جزيلا شكرا
لك دكتور جمال شعبان طبعا
الاختصاصيه استاذ امراض القلب وعميد معهد
القلب السابق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات